obrigado pela oportunidade de participar
de até então como ele comentou nome é
luana eu sou professor aqui na faculdade
de educação de engenharia civil
arquitetura e urbanismo departamento de
saneamento em ambiente e embora minha
pesquisa tenha foco no tratamento de
esgoto e remoção de nutrientes
a gente vai falar de da fonte
alternativa de água mas antes de
apresentar o diamante medial a gente
precisa entender porque a gente precisa
de uma fonte alternativa de água que não
sejam só os mananciais ou contam com a
atividade deve ser humano influenciando
os processos naturais existem a
degradação ambiental e essa degradação
ambiental é acelerada pelo pelo aumento
do crescimento demográfico
esse aumento do crescimento demográfico
especial para a água o que ele vai fazer
análise é que o senac aumenta se a
demanda de água tanto para a parte de
consumo doméstico como a indústria e
também para a agricultura
então a gente tem duas problemáticas
nesse caso uma delas é na parte de
quantidade ou seja vai começar a retirar
mais água dos mananciais como também na
qualidade e nós vamos também gerar mais
esgoto e isso vai ser lançado de alguma
maneira nos mananciais
por isso então é interessante que nós
tenhamos uma fonte alternativa de água
mas aí a gente pensa nem se tem na
região tem escassez de água onde que
você vai pegar essa é talvez a gente
faça igual à capital em são paulo que
pegue a bomba de muito longe né
aqui isso é é viável economicamente
interessante ou como eu costumo dizer
essa água pode cair do céu né
literalmente então a gente entra no foco
da da palestra que seria então o
aproveitamento da água de chuva como
fonte alternativa de recurso hídrico
a chuva é uma precipitação assim como o
neve ou granizo ou orvalho
fala se a precipitação é a chuva que é
uma forma mais fácil a gente reservar
assim como medir quem faz a medição da
chuva é um aparelho que se chama pub o
mito e ele vai medir a chuva a
intensidade de chuva e milímetros por
uma unidade de tempo que pode ser a hora
o dia ou ã o que significa chover por
exemplo 100 milímetros
significa que em uma área de um metro
quadrado
eu tenho um é 100 milímetros de altura
da chuva
ou seja gente fizer a conta dessa desse
volume superior a 100 litros
então é isso que significa você dizer se
choveu 100 milímetros é por ano ou por
dia o que é importante a gente ter essa
intensidade de chuva para a gente
conseguir dimensionar um reservatório e
poderem aproveitar aproveitar essa água
e chuva
o aproveitamento da água de chuva não é
algo muito novo não né a gente tem
registro de reaproveitamento de água de
chuva de dois mil anos atrás na região
onde tinha as populações hoje hoje a
israel também em roma as pessoas
utilizavam isso para é a bb ou para uso
doméstico então isso não é nada muito né
novo
hoje a gente tem alguns países por
exemplo na alemanha na né
estados unidos austrália que tem esse
aproveitamento de água de chuva então
por exemplo na alemanha
nós temos que eles usam isso para
paisagismo para lavagem de pisos e até
mesmo em vasos sanitários tendo um uma
diminuição ainda demanda de água nas
casas de 30% no brasil o que ocorreu na
nossa colonização foi principalmente na
costa
então ele lá tinha mata atlântica
nenhuma mudança muito grande de de chuva
a população não sentia essa necessidade
de desenvolver é e até mesmo os
portugueses não trouxeram essa
tecnologia para o brasil de forma que
nós tivéssemos isso no nosso cotidiano
então primeiro registro de
aproveitamento de água de chuva foi em
1943 e ele foi feito na ilha de fernando
de noronha pelo exército americano
até hoje eles utilizam essa é esse
reservatório
somente na década de 70 é que o brasil
começou a criar políticas para que fosse
pensada principalmente na na área do
semiárido algumas políticas públicas
pensando nessa direção de
reaproveitamento de água de chuva entre
2004 e 2005 aproximadamente 100 mil
cisternas foram feitas no semiárido
brasileiro pensando no aproveitamento de
água de chuva como fonte de recursos
bom a gente pode pensar mal então o
reservatório de água de chuva ele só
serve pra locais com escassez de água
então a gente tem lá no brasil né
amazônia tem por ano mais ou menos 3 mil
milímetros por ano de intensidade de
chuva e o sertão nordestino de 250 e 600
milímetros por ano
falar só poderia utilizar reservatório
onde tem escassez de água não
conservatória ele tem pode ter duas
funções onde há muita é intensidade de
chuva eu posso utilizar esse
reservatório para evitar as inundações e
onde eu tenho escassez de chuva o
aguativa vai ser utilizada como um
recurso é e mas a gente tem que pensar o
seguinte para cada uso da água de chuva
tem uma qualidade eu preciso pensar na
qualidade na minha água de chuva e eu
tenho três momentos da qualidade dessa
água
eu tenho quando ela passa pela atmosfera
no momento que ela vai passar na área de
captação e quando ela está dentro do
reservatório na atmosfera a gente sabe
né esses três momentos que a água fica
ela pode sofrer uma contaminação no caso
da atmosfera ela pode passar hoje está a
ser influenciada pelos óxidos de
nitrogênio pelo dióxido de enxofre e
produzir por exemplo chegou a assinar
no caso da
olha onde é captada pode principalmente
se isso for um telhado né
a gente tem a oferta de animais nós
temos poeira e até mesmo material das
telhas elas podem contaminar essa aula
tanto uma contaminação é por patogênicos
como uma contaminação química
por isso que nós comentamos que é
interessante determinação das primeiras
águas de chuva o que seria isso você
faria um reservatório menor onde as
primeiras águas da chuva seriam
coletadas para depois a água das chuvas
em terminar encaminhada para o presídio
relatório maior
então nessa primeira é a água de chuva o
que é essa água que tem mais sólidos
suspensos ou têm maior turbidez ela
ficaria armazenado mas depois a água de
melhor qualidade sem enviada para o
reservatório maior sobre o reservatório
é o reservatório maior que eu poderia
ter para aproveitar a chuva também tem
que tomar alguns cuidados para não haver
contaminação dele
um deles seria colocar nem
permeabilizada antes nas paredes de
forma que não tenha a infiltração estar
nesse reservatório
outro cuidado seria e não deixar a luz
entrar no reservatório porque se eu
deixo entrar a luz pode ter um
crescimento de aula e água também vai
ser uma contaminação pra dessa nas
entradas nem tanto na entrada ou na
saída do do reservatório como
necessitava do zé
é importante que a gente coloque telas
para que sejam evitadas as entradas de
insetos ou de pequenos roedores
outro ponto importante é ter uma
abertura para a expressão e pra mim peso
assim como uma caixa d'água é importante
a gente limpar o reservatório de água de
chuva não considera sair uma vez por ano
para que seja feita a limpeza e retirada
desse segundo que vai se acumulando no
fundo que seria um só dos suspensos
sedimentados exatamente isso em relação
ao só dos sedimentados é interessante
que
evite se a turbulência na hora de entrar
a água nesse reservatório porque
conforme ela vai ficando reservatório e
sedimentos eles vão é esse só dos
suspenses vão se sedimentando se ocorre
a turbulência da da água de chuva na
hora de entrar no reservatório e só
depois pode se responder
e aí a qualidade fita é pior novamente
então é pra concluir nós temos que a
água de chuva ela é uma potencial fonte
de recurso hídrico e ela é relativamente
baixo custo do tratamento que eu preciso
fazer para uma água de chuva para
utilizar a água de chuva não é tão
complexo e ele vai aumentar a oferta de
água principalmente nas regiões que têm
escassez ou então o que é pra pra
concluir assim que é necessário eu
acredito que nos projetos construtivos
né aos engenheiros eles deveriam
considerar o sistema de coleta de água
de chuva na hora de fazer os projetos de
edificações para que nós possamos ter
essas alternativas já nos nossos
edifícios que possamos considerar essa
essa fonte alternativa
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]